[Musique]
il y a trente mille ans un randonneur
paléolithique au réussi croiser sur son
chemin chevaux bisons au rock sert
mégacéros et au plus près de la rive
quelques phoques et pingouins imaginé il
ya plusieurs millénaires une large step
à la place de la mère le rivage se
trouvant quelques kilomètres plus au sud
car oui il a trente mille ans nous
sommes en pleine glaciation tous les
pingouins et le niveau de la mer et 135
mètres plus bas
un territoire parfait qui combine mère
relief est pleine les humains du
paléolithique venait chasser pêcher mais
pas que il venait aussi se perdre dans
les grottes pour peindre est grave et la
meilleure archives qui nous soit
parvenue de cette faune en partie
éteinte se trouve sous nos pieds dans la
grotte cosquer qui abrite un art
pariétal vieux de trente et un mille ans
aujourd'hui englouti sous les eaux ce
site se trouve au milieu des calanques
de marseille au niveau de cette pointe à
l'intérieur cent soixante dix sept
figures animales ont été répertoriés
avec onze espèces identifiées mais aussi
65 mains négatives et environ 300
symbole ceci en fait l'un des plus
grands sites d'art pariétal européens
dont nous ne connaissons pourtant qu'un
cinquième de la surface
les autres partis ayant été noyées
immergé il ya dix mille entrées du site
est réservée à quelques rares plongeurs
qui parviennent à se faufiler dans un
boyau long de 137 mètres avant de
parvenir au salon orné cet obstacle
physique a évidemment contribué à
l'incroyable conservation des peintures
aucun humain n'a mis les pieds dans la
grotte avant 1991 date de sa découverte
par henri cosquer plongeurs et inventeur
du site
si ce lieu resté préservé des humains il
a aussi été des changements climatiques
depuis 2014 et scientifique s'intéresse
au devenir de ces oeuvres et le
laboratoire de recherche cerege tentent
de savoir combien de temps résisteront
ses peintures et gravures au changement
climatique et à la montée des eaux
ainsi cette équipe de recherche a mis en
évidence grâce à des analyses
hydrogéologique que les conditions
climatiques de la grotte diffère
beaucoup de celles que connaissent les
randonneurs quelques mètres de calcaire
plus haut en effet nous nous trouvons
sur ce qu'on appelle un réseau karstique
ça signifie que nous marchons sur de la
roche calcaire très friable le
ruissellement des eaux au cours des
millénaires creuse peu à peu la roche au
point de créer de véritables tunnel et
grottes souterraines
c'est de cette manière que la grotte
cosquer s'est formée au terme de trois
années d'enregistrement de données par
les chercheurs il apparaît que la
pression atmosphérique est toujours plus
élevée dans la grotte
la pression atmosphérique que nous
subissons à la surface en fait lorsque
les vagues frappent la falaise et
s'engouffre dans l'entrée de la grotte
elle apporte une certaine quantité d'air
ces ter augmentent la pression
atmosphérique à l'intérieur et il se
trouve que cette surpression empêche le
niveau de la mer de monte dans la cavité
finalement la grotte fonctionne comme un
écrin pour les trésors qu'elle abrite
elle s'auto régulent éveil seul au bon
entretien de ses oeuvres depuis trente
et un mille ans sept caractéristiques
géologiques et d'une chance puisqu'elle
permet de conserver un patrimoine
historique exceptionnel
la mère et le sol ont su protéger ce
lieu mais ils peuvent aussi le
contaminer pollutions marines venues des
navires rejet côtier dont agents
chimiques industriels et hydrocarbures
ne s'arrête pas aux portes de la grotte
même englouti et inaccessible à la
plupart des humains ce site reste un
lieu fragile en péril et qui n'échappe
pas aux problématiques suscité par notre
mode de vie
les inquiétudes des chercheurs grandit à
mesure que le niveau mondial des océans
liée au réchauffement climatique remonte
si ce phénomène risque bien de causer
l'extinction de l'ours polaire il
pourrait aussi faire disparaître les
trois seul spécimen dessinée de
pingouins de méditerranée
[Musique]